bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui vidéo
exceptionnelle je réserve une surprise à
mon pote youtuber jeune rachid
on va lui faire rencontrer son idole
jean claude van damme il en sait rien et
croit que c'est un making-of je vais
rien dit c'est que du vrai no fake c'est
parce que ça va être ce que là il est un
petit peu malade l'appartement et de
venir on va essayer de motiver
j'espère que ça va marcher
voilà alors c'est parti pour le petit
making off vous voulez me surprendre tu
prends vous avez à faire en hiver
bon c'est parti pour un making of avec
l'arachide
si on sort d'or avons peut-être en
lattes et chaussons quoi c'est du show
son dragon ball z
et voilà je tourne pour l'instant dans
ses véhicules comme dans les films
d'action comme ta culture en douceur
en fait je t'ai menti lassé par making
of on tourne on te réserve une énorme
surprise
d'ailleurs je t'ai dit que mon fric un
temps dans la voiture et que après c'est
en ligne et c'est totalement faux a il
faut y aller en voiture et à la surprise
aller là bas et c'est vraiment un truc
de ouf te connaissant je sais que si
jamais tu le fais pas tu vas le
regretter toute ta vie
ok monsieur let's go
fait savoir que j'étais dans mon lit
tranquille et que cet homme m'a dit
t'inquiète pas ça prend deux secondes
une trentaine de grippe si vous saviez
comment limiter j'ai des courbatures
partout j'ai même pas pris de fer
allemands une fois ce sera face à la
surprise tout ça va être oublié en une
fraction de seconde
c'est sûr mais bing un peu ma vidéo noël
le bout de même pas réfléchir en disant
à quel moment il ya un making of on
tombe pas en fait on n'en compte pas
comment tu peux plus bonjour je crois
que ça fait plus de six mois pour voir
ça on va prendre les mouchoirs pour
pleurer
devant un hôtel ouais parce que je me
pose c'est d'aller dans cet hôtel lui
même et je lancerai cela est parti
attention la pression comme jamais c'est
n'importe quoi
mais j'ai eu mon coeur qui bat pour rien
aucune raison particulière
c'est ce que je fais je rentre
directement visé donc là on est dans une
pièce de l'hôtel en train d'attendre la
surprise et je vous cache pas que la
tension est totale thierry baudoin porte
que votre bébé
même moi ces jeux c'est la surprise mais
moi j'ai les mains moites la mer en plus
vraiment c'est toute l'équipe a été réel
et l angoisse tout le temps il ya
antoine berio par exemple qui s'est fait
jour de pluie etc
je crois que des gueules que je connais
et de but à l'heure ils sont tous comme
ça est ce que tu sais qu'il y aura un
avant et après ce moment c'est sûr que
là tu penses que tu peux noter ce jour
comme un jour historique et ottavien il
faut une verveine main à temps vous
faites monter le stress encore plus
arrête de faire ça ça me fait stresser
encore plus j'veux pas bien
à l'été science toujours que j'ai
vraiment monter un truc alors [ __ ]
j'ai la diarrhée la mi-temps à tes
conneries là toute façon là bon endroit
qu'est-ce que je suis content normand
oui comment ça va qu'est ce que je suis
pour moi c'est incroyable c'est possible
c'est pas possible on vous retrouve
demain le récent rally c'est le rêve de
ma vie
merci beaucoup et b6 était parti sur
elle ça c'est youtube c'est çà çà çà
alors gros moi c'est pas mal norman chez
youtube heures jones est aussi un
youtube heures on est poteau on vit
ensemble un colloque et il te vois un
culte depuis des années il a fait un
beau les fans de toi moi si mort lui
c'est meilleur c'est gigantesque
mais johnny l'a fait des parodies de toi
vas pas des parodies mais comme des
publicités à façon van damme les fausses
pubs de jean claude et john rachid
gillett en partenariat avec jean claude
van damme ont mêlé l'art du nunchaku et
l'art du rasoir pour créer le new jazz
war de noon chacun rasoir je tiens ce
soir d'une chasse voir supra s'achète
pas maintenant je mettrais de voix
il faut que tu viens de son prochain
tournage les normands alors quand on
fait un truc sympa
non non non pas tant on va faire un truc
bien te protège un truc comme ça
quatorze grandes je te faire plaisir en
restera mais toi ici au moins deux
secondes je t'attends dans la john est
un très grand fan de nous ah oui et ça
c'est normand ouais bon soir rassurez
vous pas que ça va aller ça fait un joli
petit coup de poing de gauche à
l'automne sur hector s'offre à lui
racontant poésie moments passés makutsi
aussi croiser les doigts pour que ça
soit filmé la victime avait parfait tu
te mets en garde
c'est également un grand vin est prêt we
want to move ainsi à gauche s'est senti
le vent sur mon visage tête et conclura
la mauvaise ici à tout le monde c'est
incroyable
est ce que tu as vu johnson johnson oui
j'ai vu le premier épisode s'est pas
fait courir
on a tous deux bacs à dvd allemande
johnson n'a pas peur de rire de toi dans
les cv des avait déjà la wii mise en
abyme un petit peu tu parlais de torah
plus intimes norme c'est que c'est pas
que du karaté ce n'est pas que du combat
c'est pas une série d'actions enfin même
s'il ya de l'action c'est aussi très
drôle
avec ses parents depuis tokyo
h j'adore no 31 euros en tout cas moi je
suis très content d'avoir pu organiser
un petit peu ce match cette rencontre
je suis un peu ému indirectement ce que
je sais à quel point il est fan de toi
afin de vous j'en ai un mec super ça
change vraiment ses toiles meilleure
arme a vraiment cette ambiance il vient
de réaliser le plus beau jour de ma vie
le baseball hockey
franchement ça va me mettre à mon roman
aussi wii board pour mars n'ont pas non
maintenant
ils n'en croient pas encore un peu là et
que tu content d'avoir fait ça tellement
longtemps que je veux te fait réaliser
ce rêve
et est-ce qu'il est comme tu imaginer
des mieux que ce que j'imaginais ça se
voit il partage il donne des sincères il
est vrai qu on peut le dire on est
transparent safran comptoir était
absolument impossible sans l'aide de
amazon prime vidéo oui puisqu'elle sort
ça il sort sa série là dessus donc le
pour la promo compliqué et
super les gens apprécient ces vidéos il
peut mettre un petit job tout le top et
on n'oublie jamais l'eau dans 20 30 ans
il y en aura pris vous êtes sur un
téléphone alors cliquez ici sur ma
grosse tête pour vous abonner
directement à ma chaîne youtube
et si vous voulez voir la vidéo complète
de la discussion entre john rachid et
jean claude van damme a cliqué à gauche
ici ça vous ramène sur la chaîne de john
rachid nos chaînes sont connectés pas le
mind et wyse aux catacombes rien